des moyens pour remettre l'enseignement
un niveau tout un département la seine
saint denis se mobilisent et défilent
cet après midi à paris
l'élection présidence de région le parti
socialiste a fait ses choix la droite
est soumise à la tentation du front
national notre invité ce soir philippe
séguin président du rpr les plombages ou
mercure sont ils dangereux une
association de défense s'est créée à
montpellier c'est plombage serait
dangereux pour les patients et les
dentistes c'est notre enquête de ce soir
psychiatrie des expériences sont menées
dans certains hôpitaux pour associer
l'art la peinture la musique aux
traitements classiques des expériences
réussies bien gants accueillait cet
après midi une équipe de football pas
comme les autres l'équipe d'iran
dernière qualifiée du mondial et qui
bénéficie d'une surveillance toute
particulière de la police
madame monsieur bonsoir c'est tout un
département la seine saint denis en
banlieue parisienne qui se mobilisent
pour obtenir que ces écoles collèges
lycées continue de dispenser une
éducation digne de ce nom
les responsables de ce mouvement de
protestation qui regroupe une
quarantaine d'établissements ont défilé
aujourd'hui à paris il estime que les
moyens financiers qui ont été dégagés
par le gouvernement pour un plan
d'urgence récemment dans ce département
considéré comme pilote dans le domaine
de la lutte contre la violence et le
suivi des élèves sont encore
insuffisants reportage jean bernard
schmidt
jean-louis poussèrent les slogans sont
désormais bien rodée deuxième
manifestation en moins d'une semaine
pour la quarantaine de collèges et
lycées de seine-saint-denis engrais au
coeur du mouvement toujours le même
motif de mécontentement le plan de
rattrapage de claude allègre présenté il
ya quinze jours
et jugé largement insuffisant en seine
saint denis
on a regroupé enfin ou plutôt se sont
regroupés des populations qui sont en
difficulté sociale et pour pouvoir
améliorer cela il n'y a pas 36 solutions
pour mettre plus d'argent dans la
tirelire
le collège de montreuil où enseigne
françois faujour a rejoint la grève
vendredi dernier depuis chaque matin une
assemblée générale fait le point sur les
revendications
tous réclament le classement en zone
d'éducation prioritaire de cet
établissement de 560 élèves donc plus de
professeurs pour des classes moins
chargées plus de surveillants le minimum
pour améliorer la qualité d'enseignement
il est important il est même vital je
pourrais dire pour nos enfants que les
établissements soient équipés de façon à
ce qu'ils fassent des études dans de
très bonnes conditions
exemple de difficultés rencontrées le
manque de matériel et l'inadaptation de
certaines salles comme ici la classe de
chimie qui n'a pas été refaite depuis 20
ans
deux ateliers de technologies sont
fermées parce que non conformes aux
normes de sécurité
à tout cela s'ajoute un climat difficile
avec les élèves ça arrive que ça dérape
physiquement bombes lacrymogènes jets
d'objets en cours
dégradation des voitures sur le parking
des proches est arrivé plusieurs fois
cette année
l'année dernière le conseil général de
seine-saint-denis a dépensé 250 mille
francs pour ce collège
c'est insuffisant estime parents et
professeurs qui exige désormais un geste
de l'est pas samedi dernier sur la ligne
de banlieue paris saint lazare mantes la
jolie c'est une véritable horde qui a
saccagé une dizaine de wagons les sens
les voyageurs tétanisés par la peur des
renforts de police impuissant sur le
moment depuis un jeune homme de 19 ans
était interpellé sur cette ligne les
incidents sont relativement fréquents
mais il n'avait jamais atteint une telle
ampleur
reportage philippe visseyrias diego
garcia
sur le quai de la gare d'andrésy les
restes du saccage
il était 18 heures 20 environ samedi
dernier le train qui reliait paris à
mantes la jolie a dû s'arrêter dans
cette petite guerre des yvelines deux
agents de la police municipale qui
patrouillent et ont été alertés par le
bruit
lorsqu'ils sont arrivés stupéfaction une
centaine de jeunes étaient en train de
tout détruire
j'ai trouvé l'autre complètement
dévastés comme après une émeute
c'est à dire les banques est entièrement
la syrie les barres de maintien arraché
mais il porte aussi arraché les vitres
totalement explosé sur le quai d'autres
jeunes par contre protéger les voyageurs
les passagers 20 sortait du train toute
affolée mais avec des jeunes arabes qui
les protège et quand même qui les ont
emmenés dans l'eau bout du quai et qu'il
est rassuré la police nationale ne
serait arrivé qu'une heure plus tard en
garde andrésy les jeunes casseurs
s'étaient déjà tous enfuis un peu plus
tôt dans l'après-midi le train avait
quitté la gare saint-lazare sans
problème mais à mi-parcours à conflans
fin d'oise
le train avait dû s'arrêter pendant une
heure trente après qu'un passager a tiré
le signal d'alarmé
c'est là que d'après un animateur social
les esprits se sont échauffés la
majorité ces jeunes étaient plutôt
éméché 1
il venait de paris ou de cergy ils
avaient entre 18 et 25 ans aujourd'hui
un jeune de 19 ans a été interpellé à
chanteloup-les-vignes chaque jour 400
policiers et 800 agents de la sncf
sillonnent le réseau ile-de-france pour
lutter contre la délinquance un
dispositif qu'il faudra certainement
renforcée car les voyageurs sont
nombreux à parler d'insécurité sur ces
lignes c'est une affaire qui remonte au
mois de décembre dernier deux policiers
de fontainebleau avait abattu un jeune
homme qui à bord d'une voiture avait
selon la version officielle du moment
tenté de forcer un barrage aujourd'hui
une contre-expertise démontre que la
thèse de la légitime défense n'est pas
forcément la bonne puisque les balles
qui ont atteint la victime ont été tirés
dans le dos les deux policiers ont été
mis en examen ce soir pour homicides
involontaires
reportage syrie kurt est vraiment ch à
plat
la course poursuite a fait un mort
abdelkader 16 heures au volant de sa
golf gti
ils tentent d'échapper aux policiers en
empruntant le bas côté humide
c'est le deuxième barrage qu'il force
mais cette fois ci des deux policiers
tirent la voiture nous foncer dessus
déclare-t-il
mais aujourd'hui la thèse de la légitime
défense est mise
elle parle expertises balistiques deux
des quatre coups de feu sont tirés sur
le côté depuis l'arrière les deux autres
alors que le véhicule s'éloigne
abdelkader est mort d'une balle dans la
nuque
il est clair que l'ensemble des coups de
feu tiré les quatre coups de feu tirés
par des policiers en cause ont été
tirées alors que le véhicule il avait
dépassé et que donc de façon assez
indiscutable il n'est plus menacée par
ce véhicule si jamais il a décidé il se
trouvait à ce moment des tirs à quelle
distance de la voiture ça dépend de la
vitesse du véhicule ce qui est plus
important de la distance
c'est l'ordre positionnement par bon
véhicule et il est établi que moment où
les tirs ont été effectués ils n'étaient
pas devant la voiture dont qui s'était
probablement à une vague entre 20 et 50
mètres sur le côté ou derrière la
voiture
la mort de khadr avait provoqué de vives
tensions à dammarie les lys
les deux policiers n'avaient subi aucune
sanction au moment des faits ils
viennent d'être mises en examen pour
homicide involontaire
ces deux policiers ont demandé une
contre expertise balistique trade fit
tilt blanchiment d'argent bref tout un
système de cavalerie financière mise au
jour par une nouvelle opération de
police dans le sentier le quartier de la
confection à paris la descente de ce
matin effectué par plus de 200
inspecteurs fait suite à une première
opération qui avait eu lieu en novembre
dernier reportage arnaud boutet
jean-françois peu avant 7 heures les
premières personnes interpellées sont
conduites dans les locaux des affaires
économiques et financières de la pj
parisienne
elles ont toutes été arrêtées à leur
domicile une heure plus tôt par 200
policiers qui ont agi dans le quartier
du sentier ainsi qu'en banlieue
parisienne 60 interpellations au total
l'opération de ce matin s'inscrit dans
la continuité de la sphère d'escroquerie
mise à jour il ya quatre mois dans le
sentier à l'époque 53 personnes avaient
été mises en examen
il est possible que tous travaillent
effectivement n'est pas été effectuée on
doit retrouver dans cette affaire
l'intégralité des préjudices subis par
les différents établissements bancaires
et le travail va nécessairement
continuer des banques victimes du
système de cavalerie plusieurs dizaines
d'entreprises de confection du sentier
ont émis des trade fictive des traîtres
qui ne correspondaient à aucune
livraison va être confié à une banque
qui l'a en payer le montant optio nos
créanciers
et lorsqu'elle va se retourner pour être
à son tour elle même payé vers le
pionner au débiteur
celui-ci aura disparu et elle ne pourra
jamais retrouvé son argent le préjudice
subi par les banques est estimé à un
milliard de francs la police judiciaire
s'intéresserait également au blanchiment
éventuelle des sommes d'argent découlant
de cette escroquerie
la politique avec les élections
régionales avant la désignation des
présidents vendredi c'est le moment des
grandes manoeuvres dans les partis
politiques à gauche d'abord les choses
sont un peu plus simple qu'à droite il
s'agit simplement si je puis dire de
savoir si le parti socialiste accorde
quelques présidences de région à ses
alliés communistes ou aux verts sur
place ont ils solférino guilaine chenu
les décisions sont prises ce soir
guilhem absolument les décisions sont
prises c'est un jour important pour le
parti socialiste lionel jospin est venu
lui-même assisté superviser ces
décisions à lionel jospin qui vous savez
et très attentif à l' équilibre dans la
majorité plurielle
car en effet c'était un jour de partage
parti socialiste partage des présidences
de régions gagnables par la gauche alors
concrètement voilà ce que ça donne la
picardie pour les communistes et c'est
une femme qui sera candidate
les verts renoncent au
nord-pas-de-calais ils auront au moins
une vice-présidence dans chaque région
gagnée par la gauche et probablement
trois vice-présidences en ile de france
la franche comté revient en mouvement
des citoyens
même s'il cette région apparaît
difficilement gagnable les radicaux de
gauche se présenteront à eux sans grand
espoir en corse
ils auront par contre des postes
importants par les conseils généraux
voilà pour le partage pour ce qui est de
la stratégie face au front national la
gauche ne présentera pas de candidat à
la présidence de région s'il n'a pas la
majorité relative et cela concerne six
régions
voilà donc pour les décisions
ce soir la gauche espère toujours
emporté une dizaine de présidence de
région vendredi prochain s'il n'y a pas
d'accord entre la droite et le front
national
cela nous en parlerons dans un instant
avec philippe seguin pour la droite
disant rpr udf les choses sont un peu
plus complexes hier soir ici même au nom
du front national bruno mégret a fait
une proposition de soutien sans
participation à la droite qui lui
permettrait peut-être de conserver la
majorité des présidences de conseil
régional à l'udf comme au rpr
l'état-major réuni ce matin on était on
ne peut plus clair pas d'accord pas
d'alliance et au parti gaulliste on
ajoute même exclusion immédiate
okaz ce qui n'empêche pas des tentations
dans plusieurs régions la plus
significative étant le languedoc
roussillon dirigé par l'udf jacques
blanc reportage françoise david
françoise masson sur les eaux du lez au
pied de l'hôtel de région les écoliers
de montpellier ram et c'est un peu le
même genre de sport qui se joue depuis
dimanche dans les étages supérieurs
la gauche plurielle détient la majorité
relative mais jacques blanc le président
élèves sortant n'a pour autant pas
renoncer et il a besoin des voix front
national alain jamais confirmé les
termes d'un éventuel marché baisse des
impôts politique renforcée en matière de
sécurité et la signature de jacques
blanc aux côtés de celles de trois élus
front national nous serons tous les
trois signataires avec qu'il voudra ce
sont des conditions sur lesquelles il
n'est pas question de revenir ces
billets sera en main son destin
jacques blanc en est bien conscient et
du coup il ne paraît pas entendre les
mises en garde de l'udf pressant ses
adhérents de ne pas céder aux sirènes du
front national son discours ne change
pas pas d'accord n'est pas d'exclusion
s'il ya convergence entre le programme
du front national est le sien ce n'est
pas de son fait
s'il ya des femmes et des hommes qui
pensent en effet qu'il faut baisser des
impôts et assurer la sécurité va mieux
nous ça n'est pourtant pas mieux on va
pas nous accuser des pires au mans j'ai
toujours respecté tous les élus je n'ai
jamais cédé à la diabolisation
je n'ai jamais fait non plus de
construction sur les principes donc je
suis serein chacun se déterminera maxi
candidat socialiste à la présidence
georges frêche le maire de montpellier
en appel à philippe séguin pour que les
élus rpr ne suivent pas jacques blanc je
suis plutôt confiant soit aperçu sur le
réflexe républicain
je le répète pour monsieur bord du man
membre de l'udf il a choisi les onze udf
et nu sur un seul critère de sélection
accord pour travailler le front national
léon ziegler pairs de la région se sont
réunis aujourd'hui à huit clos en début
de soirée il n'avait pas fait connaître
leur position
philippe séguin bonsoir bonsoir alors
vous donnez des ordres ils sont claire
pas d'alliance pas de discussions mais
on sent tout de même que des élus sont
tentés voir une partie de cesser de
celui qu'on vient de voir que vous me
parlez moi j'y peux rien oui il
appartient pas ma formation
j'entends bien millionnaire très
difficile de l'exclure non vous en parle
on gravit précisément disant que le rpr
il ya quand même des gens qui sont
tentés on a vu un serveur en poche il ya
péri alors que nous nous attachons ce
moment à prévenir ces risques
c'était même je pense qu'on aura réglé
la plupart des problèmes du suivante
c'est tout de même
l'offensive la plus sérieuse que vous
ayez jamais connu de la part du front
national le soutien sans participation
c'est quelque chose qui vous inquiète
vraiment nouveau ce quelque chose qui
m'intéresse beaucoup
dumas thérèse beaucoup de gens tant sur
le plan politique si le front national
d'où tient ce discours
ça ne vous coûtera et là ça peut vous
rapporter gros si change radicalement de
position après nous après fait battre
systématiquement c'est qu'il est lui
même dans une impasse politique
c'est que vous avez bien le fus quelles
étaient ses résultats il n'a pas
progressé pour la première fois sur un
mode de scrutin qui lui est
extraordinairement favorables il ne
progresse pas il est dans une impasse
il en a conscience il a conscience que
ces électeurs sont de plus en plus
nombreux à s'en rendre compte bien à
larry cherche des échappatoires
ils cherchent à nous entraîner dans un
engrenage d'alliances mais cette
alliance est impossible cette alliance
est impossible pour trois raisons il
serait une impasse moral nous ne pouvons
pas cautionner fût-ce indirectement les
dérapages verbaux et c'est ces mots
terribles qui nous rappelle
d'antisémitisme racisme la xénophobie
une impasse politique n'avons rien de
commun en termes de propositions et que
font national d'ailleurs s'il a vu
quelque chose en commun ils se seraient
pas constitué contre nous et
troisièmement une impasse électorale
parce que le front national il n'y a pas
que des électeurs qui proviennent de
chez nous il ya aussi des inquiétudes de
la gauche c'est demain par je ne sais
quelle aberration ne faisions un accord
avec le front national
ces électeurs y retournera gauche de la
même façon que nous nous perdrions une
grande partie de nos électeurs qui
n'accepteraient pas cet accord alors
vous voyez en fait de marché de dupe de
sa serait complet non nous avons pris
une position jeu là je les assume
totalement et les engagements pris
devant les électeurs seront que vous ne
considérez pas qu'en prenant cette
position ferme
vous condamnez d'une certaine façon la
droite républicaine à être minoritaires
avec 40% pour la gauche qui a supplié
région auquel besoins des patients
atteints dans les régions sont une chose
des présidences de région sont une chose
la façon dont les régions vont être
gouverné pendant six ans et déjà une
autre et la politique nationale est une
troisième pour ce qui concerne les
présidences pardonnez moi j'ai pas aux
communes socialistes ont leur compte
on dirait quand on va leur budget on
pouvait déjà se poser la question bon
nous nous sommes en position de
revendiquer sans contestation possible
la présidence dans 11 régions à ce jour
et peut-être dimanche dans une deuxième
avec la corse
ce qui veut dire que nous pouvons être
majoritaire en région face aux
socialistes bon à dire que nous
abandonnons je ne sais quoi à je ne sais
qui deuxièmement s'agit pas simplement
de décrocher une présidence s'agit
ensuite pendant six ans pendant six ans
nous gouvernaient la région
et si vous n'avez même pas de majorité
relative si vous êtes le prisonnier
quelqu'un d'autre comment voulez vous le
faire et puis il ya le problème le
problème national
nous ne nous ne reviendrons pas aux
responsabilités
l'opposition ne remportera pas des
succès par une alliance avec les
dirigeants du front national mais en
convainquant les électeurs du front
national et tous les autres de se
rallier à ses propres valeurs et de
faire une adhésion positive c'est pas
par des rafistolages d'état major c'est
par un dialogue avec les francs du tout
pendant montée de même philippe séguin
si un élu vient vous voir et vous dis
c'est le sort de la région qui est en
jeu si je fais une alliance limité avec
le front national qu'est ce que vous lui
direz vous
dany ni alliance avec le front national
ni alliance avec la pénurie partie enfin
écouteurs audience de regarder par
exemple la la la la la région
ile-de-france où la région provence
alpes côte d'azur tous les français la
plupart considèrent que ces régions
elles ont été perdus un par l'opposition
un tout le monde l'a dit répété l'a
constaté si demain par je ne sais quelle
manoeuvre nous réussissions à une sorte
de hold up en y mettant malgré tout un
président nous allions avec je ne sais
qui tous les français dirais que nous
avons triché nous ne sommes pas des
tricheurs
alors c'est une même dans cette affaire
l'avenir de la droite qui est qui qui
est en jeu bruno mégret la dir soit ici
même à la trappe
absolument pas nous prendrons nous
prendrons toutes décisions utiles sur
ceux qui s'écartent rond de la ligne
définie mais si cette ligne était
définie c'est précisément pour garantir
l'avenir de l'opposition pour ne pas
sacrifier son intérêt à long terme aux
intérêts de quelques-uns à très court
terme c'est position là c'est la
position qu'a toujours eue jacques
chirac avant qu'il ne soit président
depuis qu'il est blessé on vous amène
avec lui contre elle et par là les
convie vous a répété sa position
je n'ai pas l'habitude de répéter de
réfléter la teneur des entretiens avec
le président de la république ce sens je
ne dérogerai pas la règle mais vous
feriez beaucoup moins serein s'il avait
un quelconque problème sur ce point avec
lui merci mais c'est un hommage de la
politique le président du cnpf en ernest
antoine seillière va rencontrer le 30
mars prochain le premier ministre lionel
jospin au menu les 35 heures par semaine
un sujet sur lequel vous savez les deux
hommes sont jusqu'à présent en complet
désaccord la santé maintenant les
plombages dentaires au mercure sont ils
dangereux des études menées en allemagne
au canada tendrait à le prouver une
association s'est créée en france qui
porte plainte pour empoisonnement
affirmant que ces amalgames destiné aux
plombage donc comporte bel et bien un
risque à la fois pour les patients et
les dentistes
reportage ironie ghiglione pascal pense
d'autoriser ces noter ici bon jusqu'à 2
je suis intoxiqué au mercure jusqu'à une
valeur de 939 donc ce qui signifie si
vous voulez que depuis 18 ans je souffre
d'une espèce d'un empoisonnement à bas
bruit dont je ne me rends pas compte
qu'ils empoisonnent complètement mon
existence
roland bon temps à porter plainte contre
x pour empoisonnement conseillé par le
docteur mêler toutes ses nausées
douleurs lancinantes et maux de tête
jusqu alors sans explication serait
selon lui dues au mercure contenu dans
les amalgames dentaires
autrement dit les plombages en moyenne
ont touché un tiers des porteurs d'un
amalgame soit ça fait grossièrement
pendant 2 à 15 millions de français plus
de 50 fois ce qu'on tolère dans l'eau
potable dont une pollution énorme de
leur salive qui est mon bois par la
suite le sondage dentaire contient 50%
de mercure un gramme liés par réaction
chimique au zinc cuivre argent et 1 un
mélange facile à installer durable et
peu coûteux depuis quelques années
seulement tous les dentistes savent
qu'il ne faut ni l'inhaler ni le toucher
alors pourquoi prendre tant de
précautions manipulant l'amalgamme alors
que finalement vous mettez dans la
bouche
il ya ses soeurs de 12 et je suis appelé
à nous sommes appelés à manipuler du
l'amalgamme plusieurs fois par jour
comme dit qu'il est rare et le fassions
tous les jours des amalgames sur le même
score des chercheurs canadiens ont voulu
quantifier les vapeurs de mercure en
bouche ce patient à 114 microgrammes par
mètre cube d'air 30 microgrammes par
jour c'est selon l'organisation mondiale
de la santé 12 fois la quantité de
mercure absorbé par ailleurs dans l'eau
l'air et les aliments on sait qu'en dix
ans presque la moitié du mercure
disparaît du plombage et se retrouvent
pour partie dans le cerveau le foie les
reins ou l'intestin il est évident qu'il
y as passage dans l'organisme de vapeur
de mercure mais qu'à aucun moment cela
les doses sont toxiques et entraînant
des complications des effets secondaires
mais comment reconnaître ses effets
aucune étude sérieuse n'ait menée en
france la suède le canada l'allemagne et
d'autres pays limitent déjà la pause
amalgame au mercure et risque concerne
sûrement une toute petite partie de la
population
les spécialistes recommandent donc de ne
surtout pas faire enlever ces plombage
n'importe où la dépose sans précaution
peut être encore plus nocive le 5 mars
dernier une jeune femme de 25 ans fils
d'un notaire de la bassée dans le
département du nord disparaissez hier
son corps a été retrouvé enterré non
loin de son domicile entre temps
plusieurs personnes ont été interpellées
on parle d'une demande de rançon d'un
million
mais on dit dans le même temps que le
meurtre aurait eu lieu très peu de temps
après la disparition il ya donc beaucoup
de zones d'ombré dans cette affaire
reportage virginie fiche et dominique
maes un bar fermé depuis le mois de
décembre un bar propriété de trois des
quatre suspects dans l'enlèvement et le
meurtre de caroline le gentil accompagné
d'un des hommes interpellés hier les
enquêteurs ont procédé toute la journée
à des vérifications sur les lieux un
endroit désert qui aurait pu abriter un
moment la jeune fille caroline fréquenté
l'établissement et connaissait bien ses
propriétaires quatre frères sans
histoire selon le voisinage
c'était déjà des jeunes gens bien
qu'elle frère et tous les ponts pas des
murs du décoiffé je ne sais pas comment
bien habillés tous nous remettre
pourtant ce sont bien ces jeunes gens
déjà connu pour des affaires
d'escroquerie qui aurait enlevé et tué
caroline avant de l'ensevelir dans ce
petit bois depuis une douzaine de jours
la jeune fille n'avait pas reparu à son
appartement dans sa rue les commerçants
se souviennent d'une étudiante discrète
et sympathique est là les boulots et
puis boulot elle rentrait chez elle quoi
par loïc canal sortait en sarthe elle
sortait assez souvent mais sinon en
dehors de ça quelqu'un de normal
quelqu'un de normal tout à fait banal
ce soir deux suspects interpellés hier
dont une femme sont toujours en garde à
vue au srpj de lille deux autres hommes
sont eux dans les locaux de la police
bruxelloise
les demandes de rançons des ravisseurs
provenaient en effet de cette cabine
téléphonique de charleroi et fait même
de prises d'otages et d'enlèvements et
d'assassinats ont été commis en france
mais un certain moment on a appris que
téléphoniques provenant de la belgique
une demande d'extradition doit être fait
par la justice française quant aux
circonstances de la mort de caroline il
faudra encore attendre les résultats de
l'autopsié pour les connaître avec
certitude le procès de maurice papon a
bordeaux fait une pause aujourd'hui
après les plaidoiries des parties
civiles demain ce sera l'heure des
réquisitions qui seront d'une longueur
exceptionnelle comme ce procès
d'ailleurs puisque elles dureront deux
jours et qu'elles seront lus par deux
procureurs qui se succéderont dominique
verdeilhan patrick dachnak l'hiérarchie
oblige c'est l'avocat général qui abrite
son supérieur depuis six mois qu'il
pleuve ou qu'il vente les deux
magistrats sont devenus inséparables
résultat à bordeaux l'accusation se joue
à quatre mains mais question faut-il
être deux pour démontrer la culpabilité
de maurice papon
l'accusé a plusieurs fois pris à partie
le procureur général henri desclaud lui
reprochant une accusation à géométrie
variable
initialement le haut magistrat ne
retenait que quatre convois de déportés
contre papon aujourd'hui ce sont les
huit convois qui sont visés par
l'accusation
quant à marc robert la défense lui a
rappelé ses écrits en 91 magistrat la
chancellerie il estimait alors
inopportune les poursuites contre rené
bousquet est le supérieur hiérarchique
de papon
loin de bordeaux dans sa chambre d'hôtel
jean marc varaut prépare ces trois jours
de plaidoiries l'avocat a beaucoup lu
pris énormément de notes il puisera sa
défense dans les contradictions les
revirements par exemple sur le sauvetage
des juifs revendiquée par son client qui
est intéressant dans ce problème des
sauvegardes s'ils ont des sauvetages
c'est que on renverse la charge de la
preuve puisqu'on ne peut pas prouver sa
complicité dans les arrestations et les
déportations
on lui dit le procureur général m'a dit
plusieurs fois vous ne l'avez pas fait
autant que vous pouviez le faire
vous n'avez pas fait autant que bull
vite pour rené un harass dans les grands
parents étaient déportés en 42 la
défense ne peux plus retourner la
situation 1560 juifs innocents sorties
de leur lit
sorti de l'hôpital des enfants de
quelques mois les vieillards de l'âge de
maurice papon 1560 ça mérite quoi
depuis le début du procès rien ne sépare
ces deux hommes ils ont la même lecture
du dossier et durant deux jours ils
parleront d'une même voix l'actualité
internationale à chaque jour sa
révélation dans le feuilleton bill
clinton et dames la der nière
accusatrice en date catherine oui les
boîtes aujourd'hui son témoignage mise
en cause pour deux raisons d'abord ses
souvenirs lui sont revenus quelques
semaines avant la publication d'un livre
sur cette affaire et deuxièmement la
maison blanche a rendu publiques
plusieurs lettres de catherine louis
lahaye écrite après l'incident et qui
sont toutes d'une très grande cordialité
à l'égard du président
reportage à washington maryse burgot ses
traits à quatre feuilles emblème
national irlandais vont-ils pour ses
chances avec wynton dans ces deux
dossiers du jour
le premier dossier concerne sa tentative
de faire avancer les pourparlers de paix
en irlande en ce jour de saint patrick
il reçoit tu à washington les
protagonistes du conflit
le deuxième dossier concerne une fois de
plus les femmes
les télévisions américaines diffusent
aujourd'hui la première image d'
archives où l'on voit le président
saluant chaleureusement la fameuse
kathleen willet dimanche soir cette
nouvelle venue dans le feuilleton
sexuelle présidentielle accuse et bill
clinton de l'avoir embrassée et caresser
contre son gré en rouge
aujourd'hui robert bennett le désormais
célèbre avocat du président accusent
cette femme de tout simplement vouloir
écrire un livre
elle serait dit-il en train de négocier
un contrat de 300 millions $ et en
essayant de la convaincre de faire ce
livre ses conseillers se disait coup son
interview ses passages à la télévision
aiderait bien sûr à faire vendre son
bois des lettres envoyées par kathleen
wylie à bill clinton contribuent elles
aussi à discréditer son témoignage ces
mots de remerciements d'encouragement
publié aujourd'hui par la maison blanche
montre que l'ancien bénévoles démocrate
navette après 73 aucun ressentiment à
l'égard de clinton le service de presse
de la maison blanche distribue
aujourd'hui à qui les veulent et dans
lettre envoyée par catherine ouellet au
président américain
toutes ces lettres ont été envoyées
après le supposé gestes déplacés de bill
clinton
or toutes ces lettres sans exception
sont extrêmement aimable envers le
président américain on ne peut donc
s'empêcher de s'interroger sur les
raisons qui ont poussé catherine ouellet
a soudainement changé d'attitude chine
vient d'élire ses nouveaux députés à
l'assemblée nationale et désigner un
nouveau premier ministre pour remplacer
li peng son successeur est un économie
du 'range' il est considéré comme le
père de toutes les réformes actuelles de
l'économie chinoise
il faut savoir que dans la chine qui
reste malgré tout communiste les
parlementaires qui ont été élus n'ont
pas un véritable rôle législatif comme
chez nous même si aujourd'hui il ne se
contente plus d'applaudir aux propos des
dirigeants du pays sans aucun doute le
plus populaire de ces députés est une
femme une star internationale du cinéma
l'actrice gong li reportage à pékin
isabelle bechler tristan le bras
ce n'est pas l'escalier du palais des
festivals de cannes que draps vigan
glide c'est celui du palais du peuple de
pékin car la comédienne est membre de la
chambre consultative du parlement
chinois
c'est ma seconde législature et la
sixième fois que je viens
il n'ya pas réellement de programme nous
venons écouter des hommes politiques des
monts spéciaux du comité
ils vont nous faire part de leur point
de vue mais je ne sais pas encore de
pollestres la question faire partie de
la représentation nationale pour une
star c'est un honneur qui ne se refuse
pas en chine même s'il s'agit souvent
d'assister passivement à des discours et
des rapports qui ne convainquent même
pas leurs auteurs
chacun il représente la corporation sa
famille sociale ethnique ou géographique
par un ordre du jour connue à la
dernière minute
le véritable travail parlementaires ne
relèvent pas des parlementaires il est
exécuté par d'autres au sein du parti
j'ai le sentiment de vraiment participer
à la politique je me sens une certaine
responsabilité vis-à-vis chez société où
est le problème le plus sérieux à mon
avis c'est le chômage
pour moi je ne fais pas de la figuration
c'est bien toi ici mais en ce qui
concerne le cinéma et la télévision par
exemple la réforme de faire en sorte
qu'il y ait moins de 100 sur la
démocratie n'est pas pour demain dans
les deux chambres qui réunissent chaque
année 6000 parlementaire chinois tout ce
qu'on leur demande pour l'instant c'est
d'entériner le bilan des dirigeants
communistes et d'élire les candidats
uniques qu'on leur propose
le premier ministre lionel jospin à
genève aujourd'hui à l'occasion du 50e
anniversaire de la commission des droits
de l'homme la france profite de cette
occasion pour annoncer que ce militaire
et qui ont été en service en bosnie
pourront témoigner devant le tribunal
international de la haye et lionel
jospin qui était en compagnie du
secrétaire général des nations unies
kofi annan en a profité pour dire que la
france était favorable à la création
d'un tribunal international contre les
crimes de guerre
retour en france l'information la
communication ont pris une telle place
dans notre société que depuis plusieurs
années maintenant
l'éducation nationale organisent des
semaine de la presse à l'école les
enfants concernés sont de plus en plus
jeunes
le reportage qui va suivre en effet été
tourné dans une école maternelle de la
rue
on de tourcoing dans le nord apprendre à
lire avec le journal c'est une idée
reportage thibault de barbeyrac météo
ils ne savent pas encore lire mais ils
apprennent déjà à décrypter un journal
des journaux les enfants peuvent voir
tous les jours chez eux à quatre ou cinq
ans ils savent déjà à quoi ça sert
qu'est ce qui se passe dans un imprévu
pour lire pour savoir qu'est ce qui se
passe maintenant on va faire des phases
pour écrire c'est à dire qu'on va
commencer à préparer l'arc etc
une fois par semaine ces enfants se
prennent donc pour des journalistes en
dictant un article à leur institutrice
ils apprennent à faire la différence
entre le langage oral et les criques ils
devront maîtriser l'année prochaine au
cp pas toujours évident
travailler sur la presse à l'école c'est
aussi faire la distinction entre la
réalité et un monde imaginaire dans
lequel les enfants évoluent encore à cet
âge là de plus en plus les enfants avec
la télé avec la réalité virtuelle ont du
mal d'affaires la part du réel et de
l'imaginaire donc quand ils
s'aperçoivent que dans le journal on
écrit des choses qui s'est réellement
passé ou qui va réellement se passer
ça permet de re fixer les choses nos
jeunes reporters ont maintenant quitté
la salle de rédaction pour l'imprimerie
ici ils apprennent à reconnaître les
lettres et il achève la fabrication de
leur journal
ce soir ce n'est pas un dessin qu'ils
ramèneront chez eux mais leur premier
magazine toute une série de conférences
et colloques vont avoir lieu entre
spécialistes cette semaine à l'occasion
de la semaine de la psychiatrie un
domaine longtemps délaissée dans notre
pays des expériences sont actuellement
menées qui tente d'associer avec un
certain succès des traitements
classiques des thérapies avec la
création d'ateliers d'art peinture
musique ou les malades peuvent
s'exprimer et soigné en partie normale
caroline laudrin frédéric bazille
reportage
si vous êtes vous aussi je suis une
folle dans votre bureau je m'abandonne
avec des motos sanctionne êtes moi aussi
je suis une folle c'est chaque jeudi que
je dégringole parce que la vie j'en ai
ras-le-bol maison blanche en hôpital
psychiatrique comme les autres dans
chaque pavillon se côtoient état
dépressif psychopathe schizophrène
certains viennent ici pour une quinzaine
de jours le temps de souffler un peu à
l'abri du monde
d'autres ces journées de longs mois où
de longues années dans cet univers le
pavillon 53 est différent des autres
l'infirmier psychiatrie du pavillon
c'est lui il a su créé au fil des années
un endroit où les patients peigne font
de la musique mais on y vient aussi
seulement pour parler pour se changer
les idées
je crois qu'à la base il ya une histoire
une histoire d'amour qui se lie avec
l'atelier a dit bon oui il ya besoin de
chaleur de douceur et que la vie a pas
été particulièrement tendre avec pas mal
de gens qui viennent ici
non
qu'est ce que ça vous apporte à vous de
venir là chaque fan de moins que le
passé est oublié ce que j'étais
et justement ce que le piano ça peut
vous aider à vous retrouver à redevenir
tels que vous étiez avant mais tout à
fait je viens le second au début il ya
14 ans les patients peignait sur de
vieux draps déchiré aujourd'hui sur de
grandes toiles s'exprime de vrais
talents à coups de pinceau à coup de
baguette sur la batterie ils viennent là
pour se libérer expriment une souffrance
soulager leur peine
inutile de chercher cette méthode de
soins là mais pas dans les manuels
on a bien appris à peindre et c'était un
plaisir aussi de peindre jr j'ai racheté
un petit peu tout mon stress à travers
la peinture et vient de sa déprime et
cela transparaît pas du tout dans la
peinture est ce que c'est assez gai ce
que je fais on va dire on va traiter les
problèmes
même le très important uniquement par de
la peinture offre est absurbe ce sont
des patients qui sont hospitalisés qui
bénéficie dont d'autres modes d'approché
c'est donc un volet supplémentaire une
possibilité supplémentaire aux soins et
non pas quelque chose qui entrent en
compétition avec les autres formes de
prise en charge
fait du bien
la plus belle récompense pour
l'infirmier christian sa basse c'est le
premier sourire d'un patient c'est pour
lui le signe d'un début de communication
le premier pas vers la guérison
et des sourires à maison blanche on n'en
voit pas beaucoup
match d'entraînement pour le prochain
mondial de football cet après-midi en
bretagne à guingamp un match pas tout à
fait comme les autres dans la mesure où
c'est l'équipe d'iran qui était opposée
à l'équipe locale les iraniens sont les
derniers qualifiés de la compétition ils
font également l'objet d'une
surveillance toute particulière de la
police
christelle bertrand marques millet pour
éviter le rififi au stade du roudourou
les forces de l'ordre sont là tout comme
les photographes
ça fait 22 ans qu'une équipe iranienne
n'avait pas foulé une pelouse européenne
pour préparer la deuxième coupe du monde
de son histoire
l'iran veut donc se mesurer à plusieurs
équipes françaises premier test guingamp
et si sur le terrain les règles du jeu
sont les mêmes pour tout le monde
les règles de vie les iraniens ont
bouleversé les petites habitudes du
centre technique de ploufragan on a dû
nouer des réfrigérateurs et des des
chambres froides et congélateurs
entreposés toute la viande juillet avec
d'autres aliments
ensuite on a joué on a cédé des grands
lits pour les gardiens
grands joueurs on a loué des téléviseurs
la viande est bretonne mais elle est
préparée selon les règles de l'islam
en cuisine il a aussi fallu s'adapter
pour la cuisson de leur vie basmati ils
ont une manière de fuir c'est tout
autrement consommables et ça a l'air de
leur plaire même s'ils ont droit lié aux
craintes nées au cidre depuis vendredi
dernier les 38 iranien de ploufragan
mangent à leur faim
l'équipe d'iran à une protection
rapprochée du raid et du gign comme
quinze autres équipes qualifiées pour le
mondial pas question donc de monter dans
le bus sans que le déminage soit passé
avant après guingamp les iraniens iront
à nantes et montpellier d'ici là ils
auront fait certainement quelques
progrès en français
les amateurs de football la rule sort un
véritable larousse du football sous la
direction de notre confrère eugène
saccomano tout savoir sur le football de
a à z
le président délégué du psg michel
denisot remplacé à la tête du club
parisien par un autre collaborateur de
canal+ charles biétry jusqu'à présent
chef du service des sports et qui sera
remplacé à ce poste par michel denisot
d'autres changements sont à venir dans
l'équipe dirigeante du paris saint
germain le cinéma maintenant sorti cette
semaine de domjean avec jacques weber et
emmanuelle béart une nouvelle tentative
pour adapter le théâtre au cinéma passer
de la scène aux grands espaces reportage
stéphane haumant jean louis duzert cher
et à toutes les belles douze journées
mais les femmes passionnées mot pour les
séduire puis les abandonner
dix mille et de leurs épouses grand
seigneur méchant tom don juan à une
surtout la liberté défi dieu son père et
la société toute entière
jacques weber connais ce rôle pour
l'avoir joué tant de fois au théâtre au
cinéma la darty molière inverse des
scènes réussies des dialogues fait de
don juan éternel révoltés à eroglu
western on a besoin toujours de ces
grands hors-la-loi de cette
transgression
c'était pour moi c'est ça qui me touche
beaucoup c'est un homme qui ne ce qui
n'a pas de réponse à donner au monde
mais qu'ils n'arrêtent pas de le
questionner et dans le sens qui le
questionnent ils nous dérange et ça
s'est très très bien donc si mon film
dérange c'est encore mieux crime ne
tenant pas simple même si l on tue
toujours se venger de te faire fi dit
emmanuelle béart et elvire l'amoureuse
trahi
oui momo combien de cela nos autres et à
l'enfer y croyez vous michel boujenah
juste ganar elle va les fidèles sur un
ton inattendu et au diable s'il vous
plaît je sais bien ce que les gens
imaginent ce que je vais faire d'autres
gagnent à rennes je sais bien on attend
boujenah du music hall on attend un
canard elle qui va faire monseigneur
jacques me disais non ce que je sais du
désespoir c'est de la brutalité c'est de
la chair cellule sans ça ça me plaît
mais j'avais peur mais déçu je suis en
vie mais monsieur n'importe qui son
double changement nous séduit qu'à
moitié
le premier film de jacques weber est
beau mais l'émotion absente
comme si les costumes la lumière et la
musique étaient incapables de rendre la
magie tout simple qu'on éprouve parfois
dans une salle de théâtre
avant de nous quitter je vous rappelle
le principal titre de l'actualité de ce
mardi à propos des présidents sélection
au plaisance de conseils de région la
gauche concède la picardie au parti
communiste et les listes résidence au
vert ville ce gars notre invité est
formel il y aura aucune compromission
avec le front national de la part du rpr
et de la droite républicaine
dans un instant est météo sophie davant
20h55 piège en haute mer un très beau
film avec stéphane rigoureux demain à
7h50 dans les 4 vérités françoise
laborde recevra françois hollande
premier secrétaire du parti société
voilà je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur notre chaîne bonsoir album
je